[Musique]
branle bas de combat pour les aigles de
l'école brind'amour et les dragons de
l'école sainte madeleine à l'aréna
vaudreuil dorion dans un coin sandrine
reçoit un coup de main après tout c'est
seulement la deuxième fois qu'elle joue
jamais pas comment manier un battant je
vous les jambes arquées vous avez la
chance de pouvoir compter début
maintenant faire conter à nos joueurs
que j'ai pas nécessairement ou qui
jouent moins rock et c'est vraiment
intéressant
ici tout le monde joue ensemble
les débutants avec l'élite eu l'idée
d'enseigner en éducation physique mordus
de hockey qui se sont tirés du réseau du
sport étudiant du québec pour former
leurs propriétés pour faire vivre autre
chose aux jeunes
c'est jouer pour jouer le résultat
compte paul irin comptabilisés dans la
ligue donc et c'est vraiment jouer pour
s'amuser
la formule est simple après chaque
minute de jeu les cinq joueurs sont
remplacés sur la glace
bon ça
de vents violents et 2 1 je ne peux pas
marquer plus de trois buts après il doit
passer la rondelle
les habitués se valorisent en aidant les
autres
les débutants ce le valoriste en
touchant à la rondelle en fait tout le
monde peut scorer début je marquettois
début non mais j'aimerais ça m'a marqué
c'est ça donne la chance ou à défaut des
vues pillés ça leur rend compte en
piscine est très loin de la vallée de la
vis de la prochaine fois c'est ce que je
vois pas une formule qui évite les
laissés pour compte qui permet aux
habitués de travailler leur créativité
et qui donne aussi le droit à l'erreur
est ce que c'est un bon choix tu vois
ton meilleur joueur pour dire accepter
l'erreur de l'aube un sommes mentalement
c'est un cheminement
parce que comment de fond peut voir dans
leur cabine à l'enfant qui va taper sa
glace parce que l'otan manqué une passe
ou quoi que ce soit donc c'est vraiment
le message et cette ligue fait des
petits on est passé de cinq à dix
équipes en trois saisons dans les
estrades
les camarades de classe et un joyeux
concert est derrière les parents sont
ravis car ici on joue les autres l'ayant
beaucoup de pression à performer à
réussir à gagner ici qu'ils gagnent ou
qu'ils perdent ils font juste s'amuser
fait pour nous c'est bien moins
stressant comme parent dans les astres
abl c'est beaucoup plus ludique on est
là pour s'amuser
il n'y a pas personne qui perd les
pédales au niveau des parents
les dragons l'emportent 6 4 sur les
actes mais ce qu'on célèbre avant tout
c'est l'esprit de corps soyez plus je
passe puis au fait je suis en tout cas
j'ai pas sachez qu'ils avaient de la
misère on donne beaucoup le goût de
continuer pour pouvoir puis encore plus
de game ça ça serait vraiment cool
c'était vraiment vraiment stressé au
début je me suis est ce que les
audiences j'allais seulement comment tu
t'es trouver aujourd'hui plus jeune que
la dernière fois plus d'adeptes du
hacker par et pour le plaisir
et si diam's on verra du canada
vaudreuil dorion